[موسيقى]
وكل ما جارنا عام ان تعدى عذاب الله
نفتحها
وانا حشش العرق واستمدان الخيشروه ما نخلي
فيها ولا حاجه كنا مهتمين فيها والله وانا
مفتح الحارات ولا بالسيران اللي عنده
حراثه واللي عنده الثيران
الحياه قبل ولعان ايش الفرق بين الزراعه
الزراعه الحين احسن من قدام
الحين احسن والله احسن من قدام اول ماشي
تعرف ماشي
قليل تاخذها ولا بردا ولا تعرف اول كان في
تعاون بينكم
نسرح نسرم في الركيب كلنا نجي ثلاث اربع
يصربنا خمس ما شاء الله علينا ناخذ ذاك
الركيب ثاني
ما شاء الله علينا
عاما تعدى عذاب
في
ركيبه الشعبه وكل ما جاء لنا عاما تعدى
عذابه
وانا بعد اخاف اني
عمري اخاف
اربع سنين خمس سنين
ونحن على الزرع معاه امي وابي وكلهم خمسين
سنه من يوم ما بدينا نزرع ونصر امونه
نسوي كل حاجه
نقعد ندريها قدام يمه
لك الحمد الحصادات فيه والحراثه ويا ربي
لك الحمد ما علينا خلاف الحمد لله والشكر
لله سبحانه
موسم الحنطه ذا الحين
موسم الحنطه والشعير والبسن واللي يبغى
يضرب وكل حاجه
كل شيء يحقل ذا الحين وكلها والله اللي
تشتهر فيها ارباح المزارع والله
ويا ربي لك الحمد والله يا حبيبي الزراعه
ما في زيها الزرع اليوم تنبت
وانا عاد فتره
اربعه اشهر ثلاثه اشهر وخلاص
نعرف ونحطه
للبقر
وكل شيء والله كل حاجه
والله يا حبيبي الزراعه ما في زيها الزرع
من يوم تنبت الين نروحوا هالبيت
يكون عاد فتره
اربعه اشهر ثلاثه اشهر وخلاص
نعرف ونحطه
للبقر
وكل شيء والله كل حاجه
ناخذ لنا ثنتين ثلاث ونسرح مصر من الحين
وياهن في ركيب وعشيا ثاني
التضليل هذا اللعب ما ظل الركيب من النيه
قليل
بالمزحه وازيد اصدر
ونرفع الحصيان وانا احشش سندانها وعرقه ما
اخلي فيها
العيال وما نخلي فيها شيء
[موسيقى]
اخلى البلاد نتعلف منها
ومعنا كل شغله قدام والله
ونص الطر العيش يما ظلينا نصرف نص الطريق
ونكبسه وتجي المطران ونتعب تعبنا والله ما
تعبنا والله اي والله تعبنا ما يروح
الواحد وعاد يبغى نفسه واحد
بذيك الحلبه وذاك الريحان
وذاك الطحين نحطهن نحرق ونصب السمن فوقه
ونصفي ونصب الثقه
ولا قطع صفينا من وحطينا
البيت ولا اضيف اللي يجن لا ما هو ذا
الحين شوي يعني
حق شهر شهرين
باقي نفتح البلاد ذلحين بالحراثه ولا
فتحنا ونبشرها ننظف سندانها وعرقها وبعدين
يزيد يجينا مطرا ونزيد نقراها
شبابه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات